[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تستمر حلقه
المواجهه المباشره وغير المباشره بين
اسرائيل وايران لتنظر معها بنعكاسات كبيره
على الاستقرار الامني بالمنطقه وسط مخاوف
كبيره من حدوث مواجهه وشيكا بين الطرفين
ايران هذه المره تتهم ارهابيين اسرائيليين
بتجاوز حدودها حيث قال وزير المخابرات
الايراني اسماعيل الخطيب قال ان مجموعه
ارهابيه مرتبطه باسرائيل على حد قوله قد
القي القبض عليها على الحدود الغربيه
لايران ووفقا ما تداولته وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه نقلا عن اسماعيل الخطيب هذه
المجموعه تسللت الى ايران عبر الحدود
الغربيه ولم يتضح حتى الان ما هو الغرض
الرئيسي من تلك العمليه حيث حذر الوزير
مما وصفه بالرد الحاسم لاي اجراء على حدود
بلاده وكل ما من شانه ان يهز باستقرار
ايران والمساس بسيادتها كما لفت الوزير
الى تعاون استخبارتي مع الحكومه العراقيه
موضحا ان العمليه تمت بالتعاون مع الحكومه
العراقيه الجديده يذكر بان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين دانياهو منذ عودته
لرئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه وضع مواجهه
ايران بالدرجه الاولى ومنع عودتها للاتفاق
النووي من بين اهم ومنعوا وصولها للاتفاق
النووي من بين اهم اولويات حكومته اليمنيه
اسرائيل وايران نحو اربعه عقود من الصراع
المستمر خلال الفتره الماضيه تزايدت
الهجمات في الداخل الايراني اغتيال لقاده
في الحرس الثوري وعلماء نوويين ابرزهم
محسن فخر زاده غارات اسرائيليه متواصله ضد
قواعد تابعه لايران في سوريا وجهت اسرائيل
منذ عام 2017 اكثر من 400 هجوم ضد ايران
في المنطقه اغلبيتها في الداخل السوري
الهجمات ادت لمقتل 300 شخص بينهم قاده
عسكريون اقليميون على الجانب الاخر تواصل
ايران التعهد برد انتقامي في وقت تختاره
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن حسين
عبد حسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن طهران عبر سكايب
محمد صالح صادق يان المحلل السياسي اهلا
بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
طهران معك سيد صادقيان صيد صادقيان في
الواقع منذ فتره ونحن نتابع المواجهه بين
اسرائيل وايران هذه المواجهه كانت بعناوين
رئيسيه تختزلها بعض الاغتيالات وكذلك بعض
الاستهدافات الممنهجه كما تابعنا فيما يخص
منشات ايرانيه ولكن يطرح السؤال ماذا بعد
هل نحن في صلب تحضير لمعركه حقيقيه
لمواجهه تقليديه ام ان هذه الحرب مؤجله
وليست في صالح احد
مساء الخير لك
والمشاهدين ان يعتقد بان هناك هي مواجهه
مفتوحه بين ايران واسرائيل ليست منذ اليوم
هي يعني منذ سنوات هناك هذه المواجهه
المفتوحه
مواجهه امنيه
مخابراتيه استخباراتيه وحتى على مستوى
عسكري سبراني وكل هذه الحالات التي ذكرتها
هي كانت موجوده خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه
ولا اعتقد بانها سوف تنتهي بهذه البساطه
وبهذه العجال لكن هل ان هذه مقدمات لحرب
بين ايران واسرائيل لان اسرائيل تستطيع ان
تستهدف ايران او تهاجم ايران هذا هو
السؤال المحير والسؤال الذي يطرح كثيرا
خلال سنوات تحديدا خلال سنوات العشره
الماضيه هل كانت اسرائيل بمقدورها مهاجمه
ايران مهاجمه مواقع سواء كانت نوويه او
غير ذلك ربما كانت
كانت عمليات اغتيال لعلماء والعلماء
نوويين لكن ولكن
حتى المنشات كانت هناك معلومات عن استهداف
اسرائيل لبعض المنشات الايرانيه اتذكر
مثلا كرج لما كانت هناك مشاكل في
الكاميرات
كاميرات المراقبه قيل فيما بعد بانه كان
هناك
معلومات استخبارات ايرانيه بانه هذه
الكاميرات
تقدر ايران على او تمكنت من خلقها
فالموضوع طال منشات ايرانيه كذلك هذا هذا
صحيح كما قلت بان هناك استهدافات كانت
استهدافات سيبرانيه
مهاجمه سفن سواء كانت اسرائيليه او
ايرانيه في الشمال المحيط الهندي هذه كانت
هذه اشكال من اشكال المواجهه بين اسرائيل
وايران لكن
السؤال المطروح الذي طرحته هل وحضرتك
طرحتي هذا السؤال هل ان اسرائيل تحضر
لهجوم عسكري منظم من الحجم الثقيل ضد
ايران انا بان اسرائيل كان بودها مهاجمه
ايران عسكريا وتدمير المحطات النوويه
الايرانيه وتدمير البرنامج النووي
الايراني منذ عهد الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب لكن
انا اعتقد بان اولا اسرائيل لوحدها لا
يمكن لها اولاد تستطيع ان تهاجم ايران
لانها تفتقد للعمق الاستراتيجي وهي
بالتاكيد تحتاج الى مساعده امريكيه وما لم
تستطع ان تاخذ الضوء الاخضر امريكي فهي
فهي لن تتحرك طيب
على اساس طيب على اساس كلام حضرتك سيد
صادقان وهنا سؤال لك استاذ حسين بما نفسر
اذا
هذا التطور الاخير الخطير والمهم بان
تعتقل ايران مجموعه مرتبطه باسرائيل على
حدودها والبعض يقول بانه ان كانت ايران
تنوي الدخول للداخل
اذا كانت اسرائيل تود الدخول داخل
الايراني قد تجند عناصر في داخل الايراني
ولكن ان تكون هناك مجموعه حاضره وتعتقل
على الحدود نحن في اطار اي جديد
مساء الخير ستريم طبعا انا لا اعتقد انه
هذا تطور كبير لانه لا يمكن الوثوق
بالبيان البيانات الصادره عن السلطات
الايرانيه في هذا الموضوع لانه هناك سوابق
انه يتم اعتقال حتى وليس الموضوع الموضوع
الاسرائيلي وحده حتى اعتقال مثلا
بريطانيين او استراليين او فرنسيين او
امريكيين يتم اتهامهم انه انتم تعملون
لمصلحه الاستخبارات وجئتم لاهداف تخريبيه
وطبعا كل العالم يعرف انه هذا يكون اما
دكتور في جامعه او يعني لديه اقرباء
ايرانيين فانا لا اثق تماما
بالاتهامات الايرانيه قد تكون هذه مجموعه
يعني هواه قد تكون يعني اي مجموعه اخرى
وكما تفضلتي اعتقد انه اسرائيل عندما تجند
تجند في الداخل الايراني وكذلك الامر
بالمناسبه ايران حاولت التجنيد في الداخل
الاسرائيلي وكان هناك شبكه اعتقد قبل اش
اشهر او سنه قامت الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
بضبط شبكه على اتصال باليهود الايرانيين
عن طريق دوله ثالثه في محاوله لتجديد
خليه داخل اسرائيل كذلك الامر كان هناك
اختراقات ايرانيه سيبرانيه قامت ايران
بالوصول الى كاميرات كاميرات مراقبه كان
يعني اقتطع التسجيلات لمحطه تل ابيب اعتقد
الباصات وكذلك الامر طبعا اسرائيل تبادل
الهجوم الهجوم هذه الهجمات غير المباشره
اعتقد انها موجوده من الناحيتين ولكن انا
خصوصا في هذا الموضوع يعني
ان تعبر الحدود من العراق وان يكون العراق
هو يعني الذي ساعد ايران وطبعا نحن نعرف
انه لو حاولت الاستخبارات ولو حاولت
اسرائيل القيام بعمليه كهذه لن تشن هذه
العمليه من العراق لانه هي تعرف انه
العراق يعني ليس دوله صديقه ولا يمكن ان
تساعد الاسرائيليين في عمليه من هذا النوع
ما رايك في ما تفضل به الاستاذ حسين وخاصه
ما رايك في هذه الشكوك حتى البعض يتفق معه
يقول بان هذا الكلام منطقي هذه التركيبه
مجموعه على الحدود الايرانيه تتبع
لاسرائيل فئران تتعاون مع الحكومه
العراقيه
سيناريو
راته بعض الاجهزه من قبل
هذه هي اول مره يكشف عن خليه تابعه
لاسرائيل
يكشف انها تم تفكيك هذه الخليه بمساعده
الحكومه العراقيه والجهاز الامن العراقي
هذه لاول مره خصوصا بعد الاتهامات التي
وجهتها ايران لعناصر
لمنظمات كرديه ايرانيه منشقه تتخذ من
الاعراض العراقيه مقرا لها وبالتالي
انا اعتقد عندما يقول الايرانيون بانهم
مسكوا هذه الخليه يجب ان
النفق بما يقوله لايران لسبب بسيط جدا
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق
جبالتن هو قال اثناء الاحتجاجات التي
شهدتها ايران خلال العام الماضي قال بشكل
واضح بانه ارسل او ان الولايات المتحده او
جهات في الولايات المتحده ارسلت سلاح الى
شمال العراق وهرب
هذه الاسلحه الى داخل ايران عبره نشط
سياسيين ايرانيين من اجل كما قال
كما قال من اجل اسليح المعارضه الايرانيه
وتسليح الاحتجاجات الايرانيه وبالتالي
عندما نسمع مثل هذه التصريحات يجب علينا
في هذه النعم ايران مستهدف وبالتالي هناك
الكثير من العمليات قامت هو عمليات
استخباراتيه قامت بها السلطات الامنيه
الايرانيه داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان هذه هي مواجهه
مفتوحه وعندما حتى عندما ضربت
منشاه نابانز العام الماضي قالوا بان هناك
شخص هو الذي قدم المعلومات من اجل ضرب
محطه الوقود التي كانت هي اللي تشغل
اجهزه الطرد المركزي التي
اليورانيوم بنسبه 20% وهرب ومعنى ذلك
بانها كان اسرائيل كانت تجند مثل هذه
العناصر واعتقال عناصر من هذا النوع في
على الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه المشتركه
هذا شيء طبيعي جدا لان اسرائيل تعمل من
اجل التجنيد عناصر الايرانيه من اجل ادخال
عناصر تجسس ايرانيه وبالتالي هذه مفتوحه
كما قلت حضرتك منذ قليل طيب والتصريحات
الامريكيه قد لا تساعد يعني
منتقدي النظام الايراني على التصديق باي
شيء يخالف تصريحاتها الرسميه
فبالتالي استاذ حسين نحن منذ قليل تحدثنا
عن وجوب ان يكون هناك ضوء اخضر امريكي
لامكانيه مواجهه ولكن هذه التصريحات التي
ذكرنا بها الاستاذ صادقين كذلك تضعنا في
اطار مواجهه جديده وبدعم امريكي ان يكون
هناك تسليح لداخل الايراني تسليح للمعارضه
الايرانيه فهذا كذلك يمكن ان يكون ضوء
اخضر مغلف
بشيء جديد او باطار جديد ما رايك
طبعا اسمحي لي انا يعني لا اشكك بصدقيه
الاستاذ صادقيان ولكن انا لم اسمع بهذا
التصريح ولا يعني هذه اول مره اسمع انه
ايران عفوا انه اسرائيل او امريكا تسعى
لتسليح فعلي للمعارضين الايرانيين انا
يعني استبعد ان تقوم اي من دولتين بهذا
الموضوع
تحدثنا عن المواجهه المباشر التصحيح اتذكر
بانه قال نحن ندعم المظاهرات قال وقتها
بانه نحن
لكن مش عارفه ان كان تتحدث عن تسليح او لا
طبعا انا اوافق في الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
وقال ذلك عبر محطه البي بي سي
تفضلوا استاذ حسين يعني ربما يكون دعا الى
تصليح ولكن انا لا اعرف صراحه ان هناك
تسليح انا لنتحدث عن الموبايل العسكريه
المباشره اسرائيل لن تواجه ايران بشكل
مباشر يعني انت تشن غارات جويه الا في حال
محاوله ضرب الاهداف النوويه في ايران هذا
واضح يعني لن تقوم اسرائيل باي شن ضربه
عسكريه ضد ايران وفي المقابل نحن نعرف انه
ايران لن تقوم بشن اي ضربه عسكريه يعني
على الرغم من الضربات التي تعرضت لها
المصالح الايرانيه او القطاعات الميليشيات
التابعه لايران في سوريا من اسرائيل
الرد جاء غالبا اما عن طريق لبنان او عن
طريق منظمات تنظيمات فلسطينيه او ما شابه
المواجهه العسكريه المباشره بين الطرفين
اعتقد انها مستبعده من كل النواحي باستث
الموضوع النووي اما المواجهه الحاليه غير
المباشره التي تدور هذه تدور يعني طبعا
نحن نعرف انه ايران قامت بعمليات تخريب
متعدده في الداخل الايراني اغتيال او او
تفجير او ما شابه وهذه عاده تكون عن طريق
تجنيد خلايا مواطنين ايرانيين هذه لا تنفع
انه يعني يكون عنصر اسرائيلي او عنصر
موالي لاسرائيل انه انه يدخل الحدود بهذا
الشكل
قد تحدث ولكن اعتقد انه هذه يعني من
النوادر فلذلك الحرب الاستخباراتيه
الدائره اعتقد حاليا استثناء الوحيد فيها
هو انه الغارات التي تشنها اسرائيل ضد
اهداف ايرانيه في سوريا مهما تكون هذه
التفاصيل والاكيد باننا سنبقى في انتظار
اي توضيحات اخرى فيما يخص هذه المجموعه او
كيف حاول تتسلل ولكن سيد صادقان
في لغه الرابح والخاصر من هذه المواجهات
وتقييم العمل الاستخبار اتي كيف تقيم
العمل الاستخبارات الايراني في مواجهه
العمل الاستخباراتي الاسرائيلي مع هكذا
تطور
انا اعتقد بان هذه المواجهه هي مواجهه
مفتوحه من الرابح ومن الخاسر في هذه
المواجهه هذا السؤال مهم جدا
الرد الايراني عاده لا يكون بالمثل يعني
عندما ضربت لناخذ مثل على ذلك عندما ضربت
محطه نف التي
دمرت يعني ضربه محطه
محطه الكهرباء لو سمحت
التي تزود صالات
اجهزه الطرد المركزي هل كانت التي كانت
تخصب بالنسبه 20% رد ايران كان بعد
اسبوعين بنصب اجهزه طرد مركزي من الجيل
الجديد
وساعدنا باستضافتك من طهران سيد محمد صالح
صادقين في الواقع انتهى تماما توقيت وشكرا
لضيفه من واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين السلام
عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات